Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to take a bunch of celebrities,
and imagine what they looked as tiny little
babies. And then, we will also make them old. And
at the end of this video, I’ll also step
up to the plate, and become a baby myself.
So, what is this black magic here? Well, what
you see here is a bunch of synthetic humans,
created by a learning-based technique called
StyleGAN3, which appeared this year, in June
2021. It is a neural network-based learning
algorithm that is capable of synthesizing these
eye-poppingly detailed images of human beings
that don’t even exist, and even animate them.
Now, how does it do all this black magic? Well,
it takes walks in a latent space. What is that?
A latent space is a made-up place
where we are trying to organize data
in a way that similar things are close to each
other. In our earlier work, we were looking to
generate hundreds of variants of a material model
to populate this scene. In this latent space,
we can concoct all of these really
cool digital material models.
A link to this work is available
in the video description.
StyleGAN uses walks in a similar latent space
to create these human faces and animate them.
And now, hold on to your papers, because a
latent space can represent not only materials
or the head movement and smiles for people, but
even better, age too. You remember these amazing
transformations from the intro. So, how does it
do that? Well, similarly to the font and material
examples, we can embed the source image into a
latent space, and take a path therein. It looks
like this. Please remember this embedding step,
because we are going to refer to it in a moment.
And now comes the twist, the latent space for
this new method is built such that when we
take these walks, it disentangles age from other
attributes. This means that only the age changes,
and nothing else changes. This is very
challenging to pull off, because normally,
when we change our location in the latent space,
not just one thing changes, everything
changes. This was the case with the materials.
But not with this method, which can
take photos of well-known celebrities,
and make them look younger or older. I
kind of want to do this myself too. So,
you know what? Now, it’s my turn. This is what
baby Károly might look like after reading baby
papers. And this is old man Károly, complaining
that papers were way better back in his day.
And this is supposedly baby Károly from a talk
a NATO conference. Look, apparently
they let anybody in these days!
Now, this is all well and good, but there
is a price to be paid for all this. So
what is the price? Let’s find out together
what that is. Here is the reference image of
me. And here is how the transformations came
out. Did you find the issue? Well, the issue
is that I don’t really look like this. Not only
because this beard was synthesized onto my face
by an earlier AI, but really, I can’t really find
my exact image in this. Take another look. This
is what the input image looked like. Can you
find it in the outputs somewhere? Not really.
Same with the conference image, this
is the actual original image of me,
and this is the output of the AI.
So, I can’t find myself. Why is that?
Now, you remember I mentioned earlier that we
embed the source image into the latent space.
And this step, is, unfortunately, imperfect.
We start out from not exactly the same image,
but only something similar to it. This is the
price to be paid for these amazing results,
and with that, please remember to
invoke the First Law of Papers.
Which says, do not look at where we are, look at
where we will be two more papers down the line.
Now, even better news! As of the writing
of this episode, you can try it yourself!
Now, be warned that our club
of Fellow Scholars is growing
rapidly and you all are always so curious that
we usually go over and crash these websites
upon the publishing of these episodes.
If that happens, please be patient!
Otherwise, if you tried it, please let
me know in the comments how it went
or just tweet at me. I’d love to see some
more baby scholars. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!